Time is important and keeping a planner is a good tool to keep track of things.
Whenever you plan something,...
...make sure you allow some extra time for each item by adding about 25% more time.
This additional time comes in handy and may help you not to be late for another appointment.
Note down those tasks that you have delegated to others.
It would also be a good idea to include an address book to save time looking for this information elsewhere.
Schedule some relaxation time and include personal stuff too,...
...because having all information in your planner will show you how much spare time you have.
Be diligent about keeping your schedule updated.
The Outlook digital calendar...
...and some mobile phones that you can synchronize with your computer can be excellent gadgets.
The iPhone also has a great number of applications...
...that can actually help you manage your day and week effectively.